(sad music)
I've become immune
Nothing weirds me out anymore
I've seen too much shit
I just wanna know what it's like
Too feel again
(more sad music)
What is this?
Try not to get weirded out!
challenge
Curated by Jessica
Could it be??
Could my prayers finally have been answered??
Let's check it outttttt.......
(Dat sexy pewds)
Ok Jessica , i'll accept your challenge , let's see if you can weird me out
Number one(those lips doe)
Dancing man wearing a horse mask cooks with wild mushrooms
Ain't nothing weird about that....
It's making me feel very hungry so far.....
Is dat an anime pillow???
Fuck yeah, where did you buy that one, that one is fucking sweet
Is he naked?......
Oh that's not even weird , he's not even naked
*laughs*
I mean, I'm not weirded out.....
or anything.....
If anything, I'm turned on.....
Dont tell Marzia .....
Of course it's Japanese
Oh Fucking Course
What is he doing?
He--he found mushrooms ok??
He's cooking the mushrooms
How long does this garbage go??
I dont know how you found this video Jessica.....
But it didnt weird me out
Godzilla dance....
Ah this is the Donkey Kong soundtrack
Fuck yeah the Godzilla Dance
i love this shit
I fucking live for the Godzilla Dance!!!
Oh yeah.....
This is my favourite jam
ok ... next challenge A for Asthma
It's getting trickier
Oh my god that is a great moustache
WTF IS DAT
What is that....? I ain't weirded out, that's just hilarious
I feel fantastic , alright what is this?
*weird sounds from robot*
I am SCAREEEED
WTF IS DAT
Please be over.......
It's not weirded
I need a CHALLENGE Jessica YOU BIIIITCH
Give me another one
This one just has a Russian title??
I know you Russians are watching and i know you're fucking weird sooooo...
Let's see wathappens
*laughs*
Next video
*There is good reason for my glistening skin*
*And how i shine*
*and how my pores are so clean*
* and clear*
Is he gonna eat from himself??
*I eat little babies*
What?
You can't just say i eat little babies
*babies ice cream*
I dont think this guy shoud be allowed to say the word babies
I ... I ..I  it's just my personal opinion
And i'd appreciate it if you'd blink maybe once or twice....
*and nod, and hug, and high five each other*
That would make me feel better
UUUUUhhhhhhhhhm
This should be illegal and uhmm and whoever made this should be put to prison , that's all i got to say about that
Jessica you BIIIIIIITCH
This is some eastern European shit man
Is he sayin piss ass?
(epic pewds dance right there)
I dunno what does piss ass means but i dont think it matters.....
This is fucking my jam man
They gonna give me piss ass??
O MAH GAWD
HOLY SHIT HE IS .... insane
Fuck , i really thought he was facebook for a second there
He looks like a penis...
Alright what we got , Unicorn??
Uniporn!!
ohhhhh
(epic uniporn soundtrack plays)
This looks like an awesome......
...video
nope
Nope, nevermind.....
Oh gawd
This is awkward as fuck
Can the people in the backgroud please stfu i am trying to listen to the uniporn
It's not weird about p-- , this is what friends do , they do this
no, there's nothing weird...
no, no, no, no...
Wt NOOOO
i feel violated
I feel sexually assaulted
But i am not weirded out
BIIIITCH
Last Video
The laugh song
Some quality lyrics
At least the lyrics are better than what they playing on the radio......
HHAHHAHAHAHAHAHAHHAHAA
baawhw
BAAAAAAWHG
i cant do this anymore....
ewwwwwwwwww
BUUUUUUURN IT
BUUUUUUUUURN IT
OH GAWD
Fine you win alright,  I'm not doing this shit anymore, fuck you
made by Jessica.....
And just so you know when I dated pewdiepie... what dont let nooooo
Dont listen to her
He was a nasty person
I tag him on tumblr as #Problematic. Malcom says he only in it for the money and I agree with that. And his dick is small
Felix, not Malcom
Malcom is 19 inches , this was not made by malcom but by Jessica who is dating Malcom forever and is hot
That seems like that's the truth
Leave a like if you enjoyed , subscribe and become a bro today and as always, STAY AWESOME BROSS
He is clearly a ped- OMG
UGHHHHHHHHHH
WOOOOOO
Oh god....